sous ce feu de camp le café bout comme
au 19ème siècle prêts à réchauffer des
cowboys épuisé après avoir guidé des
vaches dans les plaines avec leur
chariot est généralement un chariot
comme ça accompagné des cowboys plus un
cuistot et un convoyeur et quand ils
faisaient des longues distances dans le
soir ils donnaient rendez-vous un point
bien précis
les visiteurs de ce festival sont
transportés de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
oh je m'appelle grand égout je
représente les tribus des plaines de
lakota nouvelle culture ancienne époque
pour un voyage assez plaisant un
plongeon dans dans les années où la vie
était belle
où tout était beau voilà ce qui manque
au jour d'aujourd'hui
voilà un gros coup nostalgie voilà quand
on ya là on se sent bien et pour plus de
réalité encore certains choisissent le
relooking dresscode coiffure avant un
déhanché sur la piste des années folles
il y en a aussi pour les amateurs de
puissants moteurs et b recul hors norme
pour l'organisateur de cette 9e édition
au delà de sa passion pour les etats
unis c'est la transmission d'une
certaine vision on veut transmettre que
les personnes qui m a le trac le traktor
qui aime la moto qui aime le poker qui
aiment les indiens kiem les cowboys
qu'aiment les motos etc etc
j'aime le rock and roll qui aiment
danser ce sont des pacifiques
ce dimanche tout redevient las vegas et
les fiancés sont attendus pour un
mariage express l'an dernier au total
trente six mille visiteurs avaient fait
le déplacement
koné